♪ ♪
>> Greg: GUESS WHO WAS
NOMINATED FOR A
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE AGAIN THROUGH
THEIR DIME A DOZEN TRINKETS, SO
USELESS THEY THREW ONE AT OBAMA
JUST FOR BRUSHING HIS TEETH.
BUT IT’S TRUMP THIRD AND FOR
SOMETHING NEW YET AGAIN.
AUSTRALIAN LAW PROFESSORS, THEY
HAVE THEM THERE, NOMINATED HIM
FOR THE TRUMP DOCTRINE, A MIX OF
COMMON SENSE AND NATIONAL DOCTOR
AND KEEPING US FROM "ENDLESS
WARS AND THEREFORE KILLING
THOUSANDS OF YOUNG AMERICANS."
IT IS FUNNY TO BE NOMINATED
THREE TIMES NOT FOR MAKING
LIBERALS FEEL GOOD BUT FOR REAL
STUFF.
MIDDLE EAST PEACE, REDUCING OUR
MILITARY FOOTPRINT WHILE
EXPANDING OUR CAPABILITIES.
MEETING ICES, CONFUSING
PACIFISTS AND GENERALS ALIKE.
IT REVEALS THE CONTRAST BETWEEN
MOST LEADERS AND TRUMP.
THE ELOQUENT STATESMAN WHO SENDS
KIDS TO DIE VERSUS THE OBNOXIOUS
RUFFIAN WHO KEEPS YOUR KIDS AT
HOME.
NO ONE DENIES TRUMP’S
PERSONALITY.
HE WILL NEVER WIN A PRIZE FOR
HIS MOSTLY PEACEFUL PRESS
CONFERENCES BUT THAT ARGUMENT IS
FOUR YEARS OLD, WHICH IS WHY THE
PEOPLE CRYING ABOUT IT SEEM LIKE
THEY ARE FOUR YEARS OLD.
STILL, JOE CAN HANDLE A BROOM,
SHAKE HANDS, SMILED THOSE BRIGHT
WHITE TEETH, HAIR PLUGS BLOWING
IN THE BREEZE.
HE CAN TALK WISTFULLY ABOUT
THOSE WHO SACRIFICED THEIR LIVES
AND GIVE YOU THE BAD NEWS FROM
HIS BASEMENT BEDROOM, AND GO
BACK INTO HIDING.
WE WON’T LOSE SLEEP OVER BIDEN’S
TWEET, BUT SOME OF US MIGHT LOSE
SLEEP OVER WORSE THINGS.
IF YOU KNOW HE’S SENDING THE
ARMY AGAIN AND AGAIN.
IT’S WORTH ASKING THE CANDIDATES
TONIGHT, WHAT’S A BIGGER WORRY,
MEAN TWEETS OR A WASTEFUL, NEVER
ENDING WAR?
TRUMP PRODUCED THE TWEETS.
BIDEN SUPPORTED THE WAR.
WE KNOW THE MEDIA’S ANSWER TO
THAT, SO WHAT IS YOURS?
ALL RIGHT, DANA, HE GOT THREE
NOMINATIONS FOR THREE SEPARATE
REASONS.
TWO PIECE DEALS, THE TRUMP
DOCTRINE.
COULD HE BE THE GREATEST
PRESIDENT IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNIVERSE?
>> Dana: COULD BE, HISTORY
WILL TELL.
I DON’T THINK TONIGHT IN THE
BUCKETS OF TOPICS, FOREIGN
POLICY WON’T COME UP.
I BET JOE BIDEN WILL MAYBE TRY
TO POSSIBLY BRING UP CLIMATE
CHANGE, TRY TO BRING UP THAT ONE
BUT ONE OF THESE DEBATES WILL
FOCUS ON FOREIGN POLICY AND
REMEMBER WHAT SECRETARY GATES
SAID.
HE BELIEVES JOE BIDEN HAD BEEN
WRONG ON EVERY SINGLE FOREIGN
POLICY ISSUE FOR THE LAST 30
YEARS.
HE WROTE IT IN A BOOK.
THAT IS THERE AND I DO THINK THE
CONTRAST IS QUITE STARK.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION BECAUSE I
THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SOME
VERY GOOD ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
HE’S GOING TO KICK OFF.
>> Greg: REMEMBER, BIDEN
DIDN’T WANT TO TAKE ON OSAMA
BIN LADEN AND TRUMP TOOK OUT
ISIS AND THAT OTHER DUDE.
I FORGET THAT GUYS NAME.
>> Bret: LISTEN,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A FOREIGN
POLICY RECORD TO RUN ON.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE IN THIS
DEBATE, IT DOESN’T SEEM, UNLESS
ONE OF THE CANDIDATES BRING IT
UP AND THEN IT’S A FOLLOW UP AND
IT’S NOT IN THE BUCKETS THAT
CHRIS IS FOCUSED ON.
BUT HE HAS A TALE TO TELL AND
IT’S ACTUALLY TOUGH, I THINK,
FOR THE BIDEN FOLKS TO SAY, LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENED WITH ISRAEL,
UAE AND BAHRAIN, SAYING IT IS
NOT A GOOD THING.
BIDEN SAID THE SAME THING IN A
STATEMENT.
>> Greg: ARE YOU NOW GOING TO
ADMIT YOU WERE WRONG ABOUT TRUMP
CUSTOMER AND HE HAS THREE
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE’S.
YOU DON’T HAVE ANY.
>> Juan: I’M WORKING ON IT.
WAIT A MINUTE, HE DOESN’T HAVE
THREE.
HE HAS THREE NOMINATIONS.
>> Greg: I SAID NOMINATIONS.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT YOU SAID HE
HAD THREE NOBEL PRIZES.
ANYONE CAN BE NOMINATED.
THE DIFFERENCES OBAMA WAS
NOMINATED AND WON IT.
THAT’S THE BIG DEAL.
THAT’S IT IS GOING TO SAY, EVEN
OBAMA DIDN’T MAKE A BIG DEAL OUT
OF IT.
PRETTY HUMBLE ABOUT IT.
HE DIDN’T GO OUT CAMPAIGNING AND
ADVERTISING "I WAS NOMINATED."
THAT SOUNDS PRETTY WEAK TO ME.
IF YOU WANT, I THINK I WOULD DO
IT FOR YOU.
>> Greg: I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> Dana: I’M GOING TO NOMINATE
GREG NEXT WEEK.
>> Juan: I SAY, BOY, THAT
LOOKS WEAK.
BECAUSE HE’S NOMINATED?
ANYONE CAN BE NOMINATED.
>> Greg: WELL, IT’S NICE TO BE
THOUGHT OF AS BRINGING PEACE TO
THE WORLD.
>> Jesse: BEFORE HE WAS
PRESIDENT HE WAS NOMINATED FOR
EIGHT EMMY AWARDS AND HE GOT
ZERO.
HOPEFULLY HE DOES BETTER WITH
THE NOBEL PEACE PRIZE’S.
IF YOU ARE AN INTELLECTUALLY
HONEST LIBERAL, I KNOW THAT’S AN
OXYMORON, BUT IF YOU ARE, YOU
HAVE TO ADMIT THAT TRUMP’S
FOREIGN POLICY HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
DID YOU KNOW THE NORTH KOREANS
HAVE NOT TESTED A NUCLEAR DEVICE
IN THREE YEARS?
WE HAVE SPACE FOR US, WE HAVE
PEACE DEALS.
ISIS ANNIHILATED, THE TWO TOP
TERRORISTS TAKEN OUT, THE
IRANIANS ARE ISOLATED.
THIS IS REALLY GOOD STUFF.
SUSAN RICE IS COMPLAINING ABOUT
OUR ALLIES, ARE ALLIES WHO?
WHO IS SHE TALKING ABOUT?
THE BRITS, THE INDIANS, THE
SOUTH KOREANS, THE JAPANESE, THE
ISRAELIS?
IT SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE A NICE
ALLIANCE SYSTEM AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP, DESPITE BEING
CALLED THIS BIG RENEGADE WHO IS
GOING TO CREATE A NUCLEAR
HOLOCAUST HAS DONE THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
>> Bret: FOREIGN POLICY
PROBABLY ISN’T GOING TO COME BUT
CHINA WILL, WHETHER IT’S UNDER
BIDEN OR PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT CHINA.
THAT’S GOING TO COME UP TONIGHT.
WE’VE GOT TO GO, GUYS.
>> Greg: I KNOW YOU HAVE TO